so speaking of fun people that want to
die
i i don't know if you're we can go
hunter s thompson but
uh charles bukowski i don't know if
you're aware of the guy
i'm aware of i'm sure i've read some
stuff so his tombstone says
i just want to ask you a question about
it his uh tombstone says don't try
interesting what do you think about that
advice as a way to approach life
i i think for many people it's a good
good advice
uh because the people that are gonna try
will do anyway
and the people that need to be told
there's a whole cottage industry now
of motivational speakers and life
coaches and
gurus uh that tell people
uh that they all have to own their own
business and be their own boss
and be a disrupter and get in new
industries you know
that's incredibly unrealistic for most
people most people
are not suited for that and you know the
gary vee's in the world that tell
everybody that they should just hustle
and grind and hustle and grind they're
very light on the specifics of what they
should actually do
um yeah i think a lot of people that's
not horrible advice to give to a lot of
people i think
i think my generation got horrible
advice from our our parents from our
teachers
and that advice was follow your dreams
uh and nobody
and that was it by the way there was no
like what are your dreams
are they realistic what happens when
they don't work out will your dreams
make you happy
are your dreams real do they exist on
earth
yeah can you follow anybody will follow
your dreams
you can be anything you want to be
horrible advice horrible advice
worst advice you could ever give a
generation of people really
truly i mean think about think about it
if you were talking to somebody
and you were trying to make them succeed
are there any two
uh worse pieces of advice to give them
then
follow your dreams and you can be
anything you want to be
those to me are the two most destructive
pieces of information i've ever heard so
let me uh push back because oh that's
fair this is many people do
so uh yeah this is like a rigorous
journalistic interview
larry king by the way passed away today
so i'm i'm taking over the it's very
scary i'm carrying the very sad
r p king yeah what was i even gonna say
oh let me push back on the
follow your dream thing is i come from
an
immigrant family where i was
always working extremely hard at stuff
like in in a stupid way i would i love
there's something about me that loves
hitting my head against the wall over
and over and over
until either my head breaks or the wall
breaks just like
i love that dedication for no purpose
whatsoever
it's like the mouse that's stuck in a
cage or whatever and
no and everybody always told me my
family
the people around me the sort of uh the
epitome of what i could achieve is to be
kind of
a stable job you know the the old like
lawyer doctor
in my case it's like scientists and so
on but i had these dreams i had this
fire
you know about i love robots
and that nobody ever gave me permission
to pursue those dreams
i know you're supposed to grab it
yourself nobody's supposed to give you
permission
but there's something about just people
saying
you know [ __ ] what everyone else thinks
like giving you permission a parent or
somebody like that saying
do your own thing go become an actor go
become like do the crazy thing you're
not supposed to do an artist
go build a company quit school all that
kind of stuff
yes sure that's to push back against the
uh follow your dreams as advice
in mass if you were to look at in mass
if you were to look at statistically
how few people that works out for i'm
just no let's be very honest this is
very true yeah be very honest
so i mean like yeah if you're gonna go
be an act hey i i was broke for 10 years
before i became a
before i was making money as a comedian
i get it i didn't need gary vaynerchuk
to tell me to follow my
thing right and here's the other thing i
was kind of funny and like
i was kind of a lot of things were
in my favor of being a comedian right i
had this kind of crazy [ __ ] up life i
had a lot of stories
i had exhausted or i was willing to fail
i had failed
before i was broke i didn't care about
being broke i knew how to be broke
um i had i was shameless to to a degree
i was
i would get on a stage night after night
and be laughed at
i would uh i had a high threshold for
being embarrassed
i had a high threshold for people
thinking that i was a scumbag right and
showing up at family parties and being
like yeah i still really don't have a
job and
i'm just i work at comedy clubs kind of
and i get booked when i can
um and i i i was you know suited for it
there's this idea that people can just
roam around the world
injecting themselves into other things
they have
no aptitude for at all and will that to
happen
a small percentage of people might be
able to do that but
the vast majority of people have
something they
might key into that they're meant to do
like you loved robots you love
technology and you found a place in that
world
where you thrive but i think many people
a lot of people love robots right
so a lot of people think everything you
do is interesting i think your [ __ ] is
fascinating
i i watch you or podcasts and i think
it's very interesting
i have no place in your world you know
what i mean
i have no place in that world i i don't
like
remedial math i don't like community
college math i think it's a waste of my
time
you